now opposition parties in hungary are
uniting to take on prime minister victor
orban and they're backing peter
marquissai a political outsider with no
party affiliation to lead the charge
he's just won an opposition primary over
the weekend and will go head-to-head
against orbon in next year's
parliamentary election
earlier we spoke to dw correspondent
arpad solzi in budapest he told us more
about victor orban's challenger peter
marquissai
well he's relative unknown before these
uh primaries happened uh he uh won an
election back in 2018 to become mayor of
hodmezovasar hey a small town in
southern hungary he actually beat the
fittest candidate to fit us being the
ruling party in hungary and uh so that
raised a few eyebrows um his background
is that he had also lived for a while in
the united states and in canada uh known
as a conservative person um has seven
children uh believes strongly in family
values um is quite religious um
a lot of people thought that he's kind
of similar to victor orban also because
family values and and and the nation etc
um come first um er that's why it's a
bit of a surprise that he beat clara
dobrev uh who is well known because of
her husband ference georgian who used to
be a prime minister of hungary uh and
under a very uh tough circumstances uh
lost in an election in 2009 to victor
orban and since then orban has been in
power so um again uh marquis i is a bit
of an unknown um but now he says that
everyone in this six
party coalition is going to work
together to try and defeat victor orban
and fides
now observers will say that orban has
benefited in the past because the
opposition was so fragmented could this
be the man now that threatens his
re-election bid
it's too early to tell because he is so
conservative he doesn't exactly match
the other very liberal left-leaning
policies of some of the other parties in
this coalition so the question is how
are they going to get along on policy
matters what are they going to agree on
what are they going to disagree on um
so we've got a number of months until
this election is going to happen in
april of next year
to see who's going to become
the next prime minister um
there could be a lot of uh infighting um
basically they they're showing a united
front now and uh and this is how they
hope to be able to defeat orban um the
question is will they be able to get
along with each other
all right i want to ask you i'm not
entirely sure if there's polls into this
new challenger but is there an appetite
to take risk on a political outsider in
the country right now
for some people for the elderly people i
think most of them are pretty well
die-hard fittest supporters
the young people i don't know a single
young person yet who is going to vote
for fidesz but that doesn't mean that
there aren't uh a number of them out
there um
there's this uh also a monetary
situation where
fidesz has at least saved money for a
lot of people and has through its
investment policies and uh attracting
investors has created a very successful
economy now are you going to risk that
to go with the relative unknown you
could and it could be it could turn out
very well or could not turn out very
well the question is are people going to
take a risk
and
again it's it's we don't know yet the
polls aren't out on anything like that
yet but they will be coming out they'll
be dealing with that primarily i would
say because are people willing to take a
risk yes or no
we can cross now to budapest where
political science peter kraker is
standing by for us dr krakow how much of
a problem is this joint candidate peter
marquez
for the incumbent prime minister viktor
oban
good morning and thanks for having me
i do think it's a big trouble for the
governmental side and
one important symptom of that the
government regards it as a trouble
that the
public media or the state media instead
have been silent about the whole issue
and despite the fact that
850 000
voters participated on the primaries
which is more than one-tenth of the
hungarian electorate
in the state media there was not even a
word
about that there is a primary and still
the turnout was pretty high and the
results were quite obvious
how much of an appetite is there for
political change in hungary among the
population
according to a recent poll by median
institute
about 47 of the hungarians would rather
favor a governmental change next april
contrary to the 44 percent who would
rather
like the government to continue its work
so the
population is divided almost 50-50 there
is a bit
higher chance right now the opposition
for the opposition to come out as a
winner
in next april but first of all because
of the
electoral system taylor made by fidas to
fit their purposes
will
make
the opposition uh important to win with
a quite
high margin so four or five percent
advantage at least to the government so
that they can overcome all the
distortions of the electoral system and
the second thing is that the government
has just started a huge uh spending
pre-election spending
to persuade the voters and they will do
their best
to win the election and
we it's still half year to go right so
the country's divided the government has
the electoral system
slanted in its favor you suggest the
government is spending heavily the the
state media giving no attention to the
opposition
does the opposition even with a joint
candidate stand a chance in this
election
they clearly do
and
we shouldn't forget
that even
in the last election in 2018
the opposition forces gained more votes
51 percent
than the government 49 percent but
because they were not standing united
there was a lot of last votes and
because of the nature of the hungarian
electoral system
the relatively strongest force fides
could win
the two-thirds of the mandates but this
time is going to be different and
if the
if
the support for the government and the
opposition would remain on the same
level as it is now the opposition would
already have some chance
to be in the election
even
overcoming some of the distortions of
the electoral system and if they can
stand united and and uh
and
do an efficient campaign behind the uh
elected candidate
the government can face trouble and
don't forget that the newly elected
candidate for prime minister is a
conservative politician that
the governmental side will have much
more difficult time to paint as a
leftist as a liberal and the player of
george soros of course they try
but it will definitely be more difficult
dr cranker thank you very much for
talking with us that was peter craico a
political scientist in budapest
thank you